ich weiß ihr wollt alle marcel reich
ranicki bei klick zum sehen und jetzt
kommt's mördern und die diskussionen
gehen wieder los aber ich finde es
spannend mit youtube an und solchen
youtube phänomenen zu sprechen was sie
zum beispiel im falle von mördern in der
letzten zeit so alles erlebt haben und
ihr seid natürlich auch wieder dran
spannende fragen zu stellen also was
euch etwas einfallen am besten als video
frage lässt den info text und dann kann
eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen
übrigens die linke hier im video oder
eben unten ins kommentarfeld klicken
dann erscheint daneben der link um ein
video hochzuladen oder mit der webcam
aufzunehmen ich drücke die daumen